ein aufreger ist für mich dass immer
mehr unternehmen mich in seltsamer
gender sprache ansprechen das
versandhaus otto hatte jetzt gerade
sozusagen den nächsten coup gelandet in
anführungsstrichen die haben einen
regelrechten shitstorm ausgelöst bei
twitter dort haben sie nämlich den dass
gender wort kollegin verwendet statt
kollegen und das hat also eine motto
versandhaus kunden gar nicht geschmeckt
der hat bei twitter geschrieben also
wenn ihr jetzt auch anfang mit dieser
denn drei dann beständig woanders und
was macht das versandhaus otto die haben
wir jetzt bitteschön zurückgeschrieben
also so einfach ist dass wir zu ändern
und wenn dir das nicht passt er wusste
ja nicht bei uns bestellen das ist schon
sicherlich irgendwie ein novum das
unternehmen die eigenen kunden
auffordern die eigenen produkte nicht zu
kaufen das kannte ich so noch nicht eine
eigenwillige pr-strategie an der stelle
da sieht man aber auch dass diesen
gender ideologie offensichtlich sogar in
einem unternehmen die eigene ideologie
wichtiger ist als die kunden und das
geschäft das ist doch schon sehr
bemerkenswert
ich habe mich auch mal umgetan auf der
otto website da ist zum beispiel die
rede davon das erfolgsrezept des
unternehmens sei es die wünsche unserer
kunden zu erfüllen das ist in dem fall
ja offensichtlich schon mal nicht genügt
um mal versuche die wünsche der kunden
zu verstehen da helfe ich gern liebe
unternehmen die gendern die meisten
ihrer kunden
wollen das nicht das muss man mal
deutlich sagen also wenn man sich auch
umfragen ansieht da sind 60 70 aber so
bis zu 80 prozent der menschen strikt
gegen das gender und warum unternehmen
dann mitunter sogar häufig behaupten
unsere kunden wünschen sich dass das ist
mir unklar ich möchte als kunde bitte in
einem normalen deutsch angesprochen
werden und nicht so deswegen redet bitte
wieder normales deutsch mit uns und in
dieser seltsamen ideologischen
kunstsprache früher hieß es noch mal der
kunde ist könig heute heißt es der die
kunde ist könig
was soll das ich verstehe es nicht
schluss damit ein für alle mal weg mit
diesem gender quatsch wir sind nicht
eure email wir sind eure kunden bitte
akzeptiert das machen ja also das ist
eine steile these würde ich mal sagen
ich glaube dass es wichtig ist dass den
menschen die freiheit gelassen wird so
zu sprechen wie sie mögen denn eine
sprache befindet sich immer im wandel
und jeder finde ich sollte die abwägung
selbsttätigen ob man sozusagen sensible
sprache an der stelle verwenden möchte
oder nicht ich finde es konsequent für
geist an der stelle dass der
verband jetzt gesagt hat wir halten uns
an diese policy die sie sich selbst
auferlegt haben ich glaube dass ein
zwang an der stelle nicht sinnvoll ist
aber ich denke dass die menschen in die
möglichkeit haben sollten sich frei zu
äußern so wie ihr es eben beliebt also
ich bin zwar erst ist endlich die ganze
zeit schon müssen weil wenn uns meine
16-jährige tochter jetzt zuschaut wird
die nachher sagen ist mir dieser mann
der welt und noch gar nicht so alt aber
was redet er den sinn scheiß natürlich
muss das kunden in den leisen aber frei
weil man weil das so ist und weil das
sonst eine geringschätzung eines eines
anderen teils der kunden schafft ist das
ist so fest gefügt in den dem sprech
muss man ja sagen so und ich stelle für
mich ist so ein bisschen die frage du
hast gesagt die mehrheit der leute will
es nicht also soll man es auch nicht
machen ich habe gesehen dass das schon
ab nimmt also es wollen immer weniger
leute nicht so zu sagen es ist zwar
immer noch die mehrheit dies nicht will
aber 56 prozent oder irgendwie sowas
kann es vielleicht sein dass wir gerade
also mit einer bewegung die sinnvoll ist
nur nicht mitkommen also ja mit unserer
sprach gewohnt aber dass genau die
sprach gewohnheit also da haben sie ja
komplett recht also man kann man kann
das gar nicht schlecht aussprechen also
ich kann auch gar nicht ändern also
entschuldigung an alle die jetzt
vielleicht mir ist das thema weil ich
das wirklich sagen was mir ist das thema
wichtig und es ist ja mal mindestens die
hälfte der menschen sind frauen und die
soll beachtet werden und ich sage zum
beispiel häufig solche sätze wie die
eine oder andere dann freue ich mich
riesig dass ich beide zusammen gefasst
hat und keiner hat gemerkt hast aber es
wäre heute und zu wenig ja noch andere
gruppen vergessen ja alles möglich
natürlich aber wir müssen irgendwann in
der sprache es ist es ist einfach
schwierig aber wenn ich eine flüssige
sprache sprechen möchte dann glaube ich
muss man muss man mal die frauen mal
diverse mal irgendwie ansprechen aber
man muss nicht jedes mal eine eine
redekunst entwickle ich habe neulich ein
buch versucht zu lesen was gesagt hat
war und ich habe da schon sehr gelitten
weil ich einfach diese ganzen sternchen
ich konnte mich nachher gar nicht mehr
konzentrieren ich hab es dann weg gelegt
obwohl sternchen gesehen ja ich habe
verstanden sind nochmal mir ist das
thema liegt mir wirklich am herzen ich
verstehe das ist wichtig aber ich finde
auch ich dass ich einmal zu aus dem 10
zoll irgendwie finde ich die diese auf
den ersten blick gut verstehen die
reaktion eigentlich ganz cool also und
zwar weil sie weil sie ja quasi die
freileitung die freiheit hey leitet also
wenn du bei uns kaufen willst kauf doch
dann zeigt waren dass wir sehen dass
hier so jetzt mögen wird es nicht wie es
otto sieht aber erstmals eine haltung
und gesicht dann gleich beim ersten
beschwerdeführer zu verwiesen und zu
sagen ja sie haben ja recht und wir
denken und wir diskutieren ganz viel und
es gibt auch viele stimmen wie sie das
wäre mir dann fast so verschwurbelt da
will ich die antwort dann bestellt
woanders eigentlich ganz logisch also es
ist ein ob jetzt dass die otto chef so
toll finden weiß ich nicht sie müssten
aber eigentlich das werden interessante
frage also wasser gleich der otto
vorstandsvorsitzende wenn es denn gibt
oder geschäftsführer zu der antwort
eigentlich müsste das sagen alle
zuhörerin
aber die frage ist
ok geschäftsführer in frage kommt diese
haltung her ich glaube schon dass das
ausläufer sind oder manifestation eines
kulturkampfs ist dass wir hier einen
einen walken zeitgeist erleben der also
probleme kreiert um lobby interessen zu
befriedigen die objektiv gar keine
probleme sind um frau svenja flaßpöhler
die philosophin zu zitieren das
generische maskulinen an sich ist schon
voll stellen ich weiß ihr nur das
generische maskulin ist die kunden sind
alle kunden möglichen geschlecht sobald
man das aufmacht kommt so einfach einen
wald bekommt in iks zukommt in sternchen
sprache wird er nicht mehr von allen
verstanden sondern nur noch von den
jeweiligen gruppen goutiert die gerade
abgebildet werden und das ist natürlich
einer nach oben offenen skala sie können
natürlich irgendwann 20 30 40 gruppen
befindlichkeiten erfinden sternchen und
sternchen oben und deshalb würde ich
sagen gender deutsch ist kein deutsch
wer es verwenden ist wohl wenn möge es
tun aber wo es gar nicht geht und das
finde ich einfach ganz ganz schlimm ist
bei staatlichen stellen er hat also
teilweise institutionen die von uns
allen bezahlt werden ländern bis der
arzt kommt ich habe eine mail bekommen
von der staatsoper münchen dem stand
glaube ich aus 100 setzen und in diesen
100 setzen waren 93 unterstrichen fünf
sternchen drin man konnte es wirklich
kaufen komponisten komponistinnen sänger
aber lenkerin und da jetzt eine
staatliche institution merke ich in
ordnung auf die gefahr hin dass ich mich
jetzt total umgegangen vielleicht gab es
solche gesprächsrunden als man früher
diskutiert hat ob frauen eigentlich
wählen sollen und dann haben leute
gesagt also die haben doch das ist ja
nicht gewählt und wieso soll ich
eigentlich klar ja da haben kann man so
weiter gleichen finde das ist ein
weiterer schritt dahin ist ein weiterer
schritt zu mehr da sein sozusagen aber
da ich hoffe es ist es nämlich gerade
nicht ich glaube also gerade die die
formel i bekunden ist eine generische
form durch alle kunden anspricht wenn
man jetzt an verkauf zu splittern in
gruppen und dann nach dieser logik an
alle gruppen nennen muss dann hat man
heute neue längere generische form aber
ich sehe nicht dass wir dadurch
irgendwie zu mehr gerechtigkeit über so
was kommen wenn man tatsächlich may not
und elend in der welt lebt halle zu mehr
sichtbarkeit vielleicht dass ich halte
das
nicht für notwendig also ich glaube
nicht dass man tiere die man möglichst
oft ihnen sagte dass dann menschen sagen
okay jetzt als ärztin okay das können
auch frauen seien dann wenn ich jetzt
ärztin ich glaube darauf kommen die
menschen von alleine dann an dass
behörden die amt männern fällt mir
gerade nur ein die genau das wird selbst
bezeichnen das fand ich glaube wir
werden sind vorhin ist ja der begriff
sprach gewohnheit gefallen also ich
selber bin jetzt nicht die größte
verfechterin des senders aber ich glaube
schon dass es ja um die perspektive
gehen sie verstehen vielleicht aus ihrer
perspektive nicht unbedingt warum denn
dann erforderlich ist es geht ja aber um
die minderheiten die sich an der stelle
repräsentiert fühlen in dieser sprach
konstruktion und ich glaube dass man
sozusagen in die zukunft blicken muss
und in die entwicklung einer
gesellschaft sprache hat sich schon
immer entwickelte sprechen heute auch
nicht mehr so wie goethe und schiller
und das war ein prozess der sich quasi
entwickelt oktroyiert sprach er wie
keiner sprache wirklich so vorgegeben
eben gar nicht in errichtung einer
konsole regisseurin sagt mir jetzt